[Music]
they need the agus as follows the cheese
if they can have any chance against LF
wine being through wax down against them
and it looks like with the Marvin
rolling ball to Auburn he Johnson here
safe is a nice
Mugi level 25 good luck all your but the
beginning gradually try to get a jump
even found the black hole it is obligate
me to that get the definitive Austin
George because it can be alive beautiful
play from Charles de Menezes down to
Sonic by flora vegetables a triple G
unusual eating me haha what a play there
the miracle is hammering the throws down
quickly if he moves anyone's the fourth
up the BK me Rakesh Oracle not you
without beating agent Ross
the age of the way puppies down secret
are examples now miracle tasting for
three opponent the double die back food
that just might be the Lena Brandt steps
are falling moldy bread crumbling good
for the female problem al I think the
size of our beanies device to the ice
blood is going to connect the zorb all
over the universe it's very creative
women trap not the eating does he
actually bought nothing will reduce the
bulk of the double kill taking out the
FS pre that the game savings from male
baby by coming out is I bounce bounce
chickens the face and oh the butt I mean
he's buying a private way
oh my god my eyes I can't believe it
golfer I'm trying to go for fodder with
that mana burn or they get the photo
special time in this silence is not
going to get the chance to get other
gears or is he he's still alive at the
time being there's a puppy but look a
bit photosensitive touches the forward
them OPP they have to back up cloud9 has
taken one they've taken two and they'll
chase down for more they're scanning to
see where else it goes flying get a
scallop MF s oblique line so if over on
the way but not the tiger they want is
better in the sense he kicks it a double
horse honestly on me baby why is
lawrence the BJP aspire from it and the
cable are damaged they were not
expecting that again he keeps just
farming nearby oh damn 33 just bumped up
down and now Randy stuck again five
heroes the quote comes out but it's just
not enough the Oracle the last one alive
can you really do anything about these
two he still wanted to play around with
him Papa Razzi jumps for it gets the
store mama connection with God out in
time from the imboca miracle now turning
40 towards paparazzi ready to go back in
sinus top I mean it's a long aspiration
on this island if a siphon attempted but
the Lincoln Spears there to block it set
up again with the meat recovery GH back
in with the echo slam they are going to
get pulled for the core still takes the
Carter down pop that ages sliding
forward looking with those fights does
get the roll-off miracle and GH can they
take Scott it down a second time he's
got the BKB silence there on to gh gh
rounded kuraki coming back in sunstrike
connects on a boat there's the AoE
definitely brought the right clips fly
up miracle he is absolutely doing in
here he's taken out a second he's not
done yet the BKB ways out there will
disarm Erica but he still continues to
throw out with these implications
miracle still around though he wants to
go back any gets vision just in time on
two super Weaver's God connect the
sunchokes BAM miracle does it takes down
another make a kill streak at the moment
for miracle or literally hammer here the
miracles show here really is turning
into it get in there he needs to go now
he needs to know well there's no traffic
just gonna get this one right he sells
perfectly can you don't you does
highlight I oh that is a big deal for
him got the cheese as one of the chief
cook even if you buy back you don't have
rupture oh that's very fast couple
really they're going to go in for this
whatever the fine that should be dead
people on the side of Elif why to get
the live beer at this I wrote PDC last
month on the use up in the air from the
earth fear there's no way he's getting
out of that they have to damage output
papers forward wins it's done and
where's the controls like it's
celebration grunts for memories of the
case that bp's are coming in the agency
Pharmacy darling doing the work city
doesn't Ullman look even a killer - no
one's that's the one they have against
the mantra Stillwater by snow level fall
down buybacks have to be committed you
serve another 3k my father agents and
miracles they're holding their pee gave
me redacted good this to me the dice
axes to be the dude purpose it was
diggin size right now it could be over
for here I thought Roberta drugs they
thought they ran it I guess yeah - three
minutes that's all they get is another
male a rat can they believe it okay
because make it again just the tall them
onto a flavor flav short super moving
forward with the stock a spooky here we
will get taken out big cheer for super
up with your to OFCCP all throughout the
kendama division being
they call in Genesis tell me kitty would
use the arm a leg forward knowing that
he wants to get something out of this
BKB to be anywhere up to coast
incredible - great black hole from here
this solves all the weight Empire gets
demolished and Tim all wait for the
timing error Sean is low cycling Daggett
goes in rockets a small brush on till by
the die baby and we met up to CST
lacquering on top of evil deeds of the
PvP Chris trying to keep him alive maybe
with an uphill we'll see if he does pop
or not he does needs back to four lives
they had to fly back from the Weaver
they need to win this Viper Raven speed
in the thick of this is looking for the
crisp image will fall they'll lose the
Dimitri's like the Barra strike rate
movement was by different in they need a
little bit more hippie and see they
haven't done it just yet one four three
seven will fall is thereby back you've
still got Tim's as well as Raven this
new man Vasser army feeling of Evil
Geniuses
the understand that if they get a big
win here I can take Roche and cheese
cheese and agents looking for the leap
for
[Applause]
[Music]
Mason wants to be give me try to tell me
he'll maybe maybe the life dr. pol my
father looking to get up sit down get
the old truck he's looking for the wrong
place for perhaps Joseph AG we're going
to DP out there get the toilet he's gone
for the ridge
there's no absolutely destroying digital
carries was in the Murnane one chance to
repair all of that damage and now you're
gonna be catching three Zumba audience
with a burger for the wrongful drop and
the final boss to connect develop y3e
recorded vitamins in order to kill the
rumors okay then try to run out but
again I'm very bad with the ploy is to
make the impossible or run away this
time under
Crippler brought down the top blade why
do three OCD are going to take this
plate and have will start trying to find
the angle and now the first comes out it
doesn't catch a whole liner just to cook
up the what is the road waiting for the
show ahead for cry coming
Oh
agent solar by 11 they going to keep
taping and out flights flying and he's
gonna go down Jack he's that back he's
been apart it's gonna be dead they are
all bad LDL cheating making it happen
the Tahoe but the Curtis fee will make
up for it can they bring down miracles
that miss Brittany hasn't got right as
we get to relocated out
io GA there to save the day the fire
back coming in from cold 11 act how's
the food - yeah otherwise - why we're
both making sure he can punish the
aggression of liquid PA trying to get
his way out of man did he fly out and he
TP home th what it look like I want to
go in turning again their position
bottom the towers dropping very low it's
trying to get the night up here by for
anyone right now that the towers go so
they know that it's going to be notes
evening backup so immediately Cape he
closes in hora clay and now panning he's
got the dog out o the job the boy games
they be doing it oh my god city s again
and this is war now burning there with
the illusion by Cronus the stand still
hold your breath and hope for the best
play bottom Lane Hotel he's been gone on
top metamorphoses been used to find a
way out of this one and little is likely
to scream chastened done hotels drinking
with the tangos he goes around the tree
ring around the Rosie no sale
shooting once again exactly maybe we can
get this kill no tell he tries to fly
out of there but he's got make the tower
gets the kill no tell doesn't even do
any damage it is just in oh this is when
you pounce all all my overall where's
the control everything to get sliced
they're actually opened with the
people's garages and stuff while Buffy
will die up on my name the top gas noble
stays from the Reapers site but if they
did called some of them control his
answer for a second but not long enough
and get a one-for-one trade off they is
still lose no tell who was trying to
saddle the backline you're right
okay maybe down scott-free tip attained
up here Ike so false obtuse straight
through the middle of the chain chakram
is back up for MSS change forward
Cochran's down G rack mr. Michael
Flatley right now Lord of the tusks and
speaking of like getting charged that is
exactly what that prolonged way to go
for the smoke gank right just wants to
farm a wave and he will blink out of
time but still puppy gets the rate for
the never sick the world its amount of
safeties I diving on Miz they're going
to try to catch up the batrider spin and
the win
Oh G grab the kill on 11 on the Toronto
and looking for iron around the ward get
drop the Sun comes through ten day
locking down the wyvern curse to keep
no-till alive see Omni questions was way
out of that track but still maybe a
persistent Achille Warren keeps them
alive and incredibles games by Big Daddy
and now the lockdown the bolo
Tommy trying to duke it out leaving but
not leavin hard enough he does blink
he'll
question is getting makeup out in time
he's able to do sir global South peak up
the Youth Center revival as well
breaking free universe into the phase
shift and only the debate out the cake
he'll escape the cake and global vowels
of burn for you know the land the arrows
courses you've added shields removal
hood making them further away like that
rdz bottom high but you're making the
mover he's going to get out of an edge
triple see I'm faith both looking for
they will get the glues fiber all the
temperature across because for the TPL
RCZ the tent a madman gets away in the
Korea be hounded by for batrider also
gets caught this is going to be future
for the people and last those low that
the visitor from 11 God he would love an
echo by King before he says but it's too
late
back down predicting OD making all the
right moves here down the stretch
they're gonna bring the night so again
as well they've got a 82nd to work with
go toy soldier note that writer no
flying beads in the night and now they
change forward out comes the Jade cause
once again bouncing deeply direct there
with the lasso tikki maybe on the fight
but down he goes 11 stays alive oh gee
looking for more they're going to chain
them up can they walk them down the
bristle back serve it again they door
him maybe finding additional clothes
though he don't bring up life supports
up in place
they have wrangled the bristle they look
to finish him off he's dropping his drop
a but maybe comes again
triple kill for ham looking for you get
security at 62nd I'll reach one time a
part on no tell and you have to walk
their local perfect vision there's the
jump formalities first on to fade
normally to commit the old because they
don't need a black hole for that one
that's the sharpened down our TV will
transform and they may look to take more
tape me control for the moment
absolutely perfect
they take their three they dip the ages
as well movie will okay position there
is a four step before s to the
initiation rates quite long as Triple C
BKB complete and they are going to make
the move they wrangle up the lake and he
doesn't even get the neck above
focus done immediately both are comes in
the both promises they're at the
epicenter again on point from Kaka do we
identify huge bonus Triple C pops one
looking for more diving not focusing do
boo turns back and make sure work of him
but mason stances grab fights his way
through this BKB he's got too much armor
no he shadow blades away s triple C's
into deep and even with the mount stick
he doesn't have the damage he lacks the
firepower up at lake in saving the day
he survives five down all right here we
go big poke initiation Alice secondly to
the charge goes for the lasso
tries to find that Eartha lock them down
control on the cobble committed it
actually hits three who all ran into it
but still the earth so stays alive
silent stuff
no candy bowl knows the under HIPAA
phrase but meanwhile the stolen Requiem
turns it around phonetic on their heels
because of its perhaps but no qo with a
BKB tries to hang on it's all of the
odds if excited controlled who's the
real man - number one faster still
okay it doesn't mean I think he could
have just ran and let the poison do the
work ouch it rescues a gem keep me
somebody's gotta make it though he made
a hope but he died but he got the gem
home and that's the most important thing
what a crazy rollercoaster warming in on
the CMC creating that shadow demon law
we've got to use the first Manus
eventually now the goals of throne
attend a journey through on x45 one
magnetized not going to be not available
for now and og close it off with a
static storm more damage coming out the
Luna turn behind on desperation mode
they are about to drop the O field Aziza
whoa just stop actually declared gusta
with a banjo threeie foliage og have
overplayed their hand if I lose on this
haul bkb's any committee now the
banished oh wow the desert time blocks
balls they won't mind control of the
tree and ball Chronos we will be able to
do that death was done in Cades liquid
one tried fight and while our doors to
pull out even taken the entire way this
bill imposition
so private didn't global that I really
thought they were going to global that
Phil observer Ward room they have good
vision here from Yahoo at bar a strike
in there goes your global silence th the
call down is all the way gh board down
this is the girl 5 MIDI a car slam from
mind control right on the money
circle will come in for the cleave
damage as well FB Center from the f-bomb
picks up the back boys amicus Alderdice
get on a daily lowlife the tethers it
heals up and has balls of steel system
with miracle in the middle of the fight
here comes the next south of aggression
LGD smoked up and out in front to Tran
revealed it and ice it off when he gets
caught out here
can they lasso him down they do have it
available they drag him back in the pick
them off they lost the shaker though it
was a good start from on it but the
persistence though he does begin to pay
off miss jeren moves it he does the last
orbital but he's going to die very
quickly here these noise manage to get
it off drink you maybe a deeper 6 on a
person down fence the folks over flying
out army joins the fray this personal
tax police me an OG scrambling the
retreat keeps up chasing forward can
make it up successfully he's trying to
focus on no tell here
don't few seconds for the supple Gator
but the frost armor keeps of a life the
shock wave forces them away and oh jeez
end up breaking evenly here after what
looks like a very bad start on food
psyche no favor all in coaster [ __ ] a
new feeling to show the bunny became
becomes everybody turning to walk that
decency imagining you to death
Whipple a fiber they give the cool the
brain Mouse does that accelerated a
little ball still alive they talk we
hang together
before the Diego 78250 white boy day mr.
de Leon size up it they know that news
that liquid have to come from the south
to exit out already
miracle spinning inside the pit row shot
down for the back wall is about the down
speaking to be able to find to be
anymore
Samantha Fox doing business for moments
people decide heavy damage in the movie
home territory the virus right not
hitting the money
Kaka have to retreat back down again to
play both making it difficult the
liquidus to get out is still free but
now abused by now from miracle cracking
up new game and the vomiting streaks and
the big advances knew he had just
disappeared to reiax point was all about
miracle the bars are Akaka bill connect
all of [ __ ] became me he'll give us off
the mountain quotes the middle of the
field song is recorded on the sphere
[Applause]
it appears of Wendy's evening the cave
in the history of international to wife
walks the grand final 3-0 victory
[Applause]
you